en la noche de ayer terminaron los tres
debates presidenciales en los que los
siete candidatos a las elecciones del
próximo 18 de junio hablaron sobre los
principales problemas que tiene irán
actualmente especialmente esa profunda
crisis económica a la cual la mayoría de
los candidatos atribuyeron como
responsable al gobierno del presidente
de hasan rohan y sin tener en cuenta las
fuertes sanciones económicas a las que
está sometido irán oa la pandemia pero
negar estos problemas ha sido la
tendencia de estas elecciones que han
estado marcadas desde el comienzo por la
decisión del consejo de guardianes de
solo aceptar dos de los nominados
candidatos de ese sector reformista o
moderado al que pertenece el gobierno el
5 de los candidatos restantes son
conservadores especialmente el clérigo y
jefe de la justicia ibrahim raeissi un
religioso radical que si no pasa lo
contrario será llamado a ser el próximo
presidente iraní eso no significa que
sea el hombre
que tenga mayor popularidad en el país
sino porque estas elecciones pueden
estar marcadas por el absentismo como ya
lo dicen las encuestas hay un gran
movimiento invitando a no votar en
respuesta también a esta decisión del
consejo de guardianes pero esto lo
veremos el viernes